citizens of the reject nation we've got
the trailer for the mandalorian season three
i've been waiting for this so badly i'm excited
john how are you i am the way yes you are
andrew gordon i'm excited greg how are you
yes this is good all right ladies and gentlemen
use the force to leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated let's see what's going on excited
to react to the show right here on the chanel
this is the one that you saved
you are as its father a clan
of two
now here we go here we go
wow you have removed your helmet
he had to armorer and you
are a mandalorian no more
yeah goosebumps everywhere yeah
poketan your cult holy [__] what
fractured our people cult fractured
our people where were you then
did you think your dad was the only
mandalorian at that groove cargo man look at fly
kelly motto all right kid hang on
you ready for an adventure
nipple chills right now nice
i might be like super biased here but that
was like one of the best star wars trailers
i think i've pretty damn good it's pretty damn
good that was blending of what has come before
and what is to come what exactly is going
on in mandalore here guys a lot of conflict
i mean because obviously boca tan her lifelong
mission to rule the lord that seat this is amazing
you saw those other mandalorian did she was
she the one who had the line about something
about a cult disrupting things yeah about you
basically disrupting things and causing a rift
and he was teaming up with other mandalores so it
was looking like there there's the potentiality of
a possible civil war in our hands at mandalore
well yeah it seems like this is going to dive
directly into the remnants of the mandalorian
cultures that are all scattered around and now
yeah maybe because dinjaran is making such a
you know presence for himself across the galaxy
maybe it's going to reignite some old tensions and
bring to add some of these timeless political and
warring you know conflicts well mandalore
i mean there's not really much to claim at
this point with mandalore other than your pride
at this point worth a lot of vandalism has been
through the ringer and i know how much it means
to bo katan so you know obviously at some point
in this show she's probably going to challenge
him to get that freaking dark saber yeah it seems
like there's a much bigger threat here other than
because like this whole thing i'm wondering like
could it really be a civil war because they really
just have to fight it out if it's all about the
dark saber because if you get the dark side where
you rule mandalore or is there actually a bigger
threat at hand and carlos rosita was on stage yeah
he was on stage and he basically according to the
report said that you know you're going to see a
whole new side of moff gt and you've never seen
this guy in a vulnerable position and you're
going to see new dimensions to him due to that
so i'm curious as to how they're going to
bring him back and recontextualize him well
you saw dr pershing in this trailer so i wonder
if there's something that's going to happen there
which involves breaking him out i wonder who's
holding him is that what grief is that what group
cargo's doing is he the one holding off gideon
anyway andrew oh my god you're here no andrew
no i got carried away there sorry about that
andrew that's all good i'm a good host i'd like
to uh no not to include the guests that trailer
looked i mean visually was amazing it feels like
the budget has really gone up on this show too i
mean the first two seasons i mean i i felt like it
had a big budget too but just this is on like
a different like the scope feels a lot bigger
the visuals were impressive not that they weren't
in the first two seasons they were amazing but
the thing that always draws me the most into
it is the relationship between grogu and jean
i mean they are just i love that you really get
that father-son relationship between the two
of them and that's what just you know and gets
me so invested but the visuals and the the the
action sequences that we get it's just it looks so
incredible i love the cinematography in this and
i mean it just looks incredible i love the first
two seasons of this show and it i know i'm one
of the rare few likes book of boba fett but i
actually like that show i thought that was uh cool
and i i think what i love the most about uh what
this show does what john favreau and dave filoni
do with this show is they really bring a sense
of nuance and balance to like the western side of
star wars like do a good mash of blending
between the two and that's what i love so
much about this show so uh but this trailer
was i i think he put it past one of the best
star wars trailers i've ever seen too and
i loved him just god dang groku is so damn
adorable isn't he yeah he is absolutely did we
see a baboo frick at one point i thought i did
definitely freaking there i don't know if it's
is it the actual babu frick or is it there is
only one there is only one there can only be one
baboo frick in this world but this just looks
like such a cool buildup too because like over the
course of the seasons of the mandalorian and even
the moments he's in boba fett like there are you
know there's called into question the legitimacy
of his whole you know being as a mandalorian it
seems like by season three that could be a really
rewarding build because it's not been like the
point but it's been a prominent detail and now it
looks like that is gonna be like ex like directly
in conflict and directly in the main part of the
story now i mean yeah like it's as we explored
a little bit more in the mandalorian season two
and then with having mandalorian characters
especially in like the animated series and such
you get the opportunity to see that there's
different ways kind of like different
denominations i would say of mandalorian religion
and i i'm very fascinated to see how they'll
do that here or explore that subject matter
and see what comes at odds within that realm
considering that you're getting all kinds of
mandalorians it's funny like in book of boba fett
when you left off with mando it was like uh you
can no longer be part of us because you took your
helmet off and now there's going to be so many men
over here they're gonna call this the mandalorians
not really because it seems at least in the visual
language like there are some of them out there who
are yeah like there are some of them out there
who are like uh apt to follow him and they're
obviously the ones who are more on bogatan's side
right so yeah i'd be curious to see i i doubt that
uh the armorer's you know decree that he is no
longer a mandalorian is going to fully have stuck
by the time we meet up with him again oh man looks
i wonder what the ultimate big threat is this time
because because the other two seasons have
been about you know grogu specifically
yeah yeah and or like that's a that's part of the
main objective is dealing with grogu so obviously
there's going to be something i played with
with dominance with mandalore but there's got
to be some other massive threat going on as is
there going to be a new story for grogu other
than just like okay i guess we're powering around
forever now and i got to keep you safe cool with
that storyline too though but i mean yeah i love
that visual reference too we got with the asteroid
field from empire strikes back yeah and i guess
you could say attack of the clones when uh jango
fett is uh being chased by obi-wan kenobi but that
was a cool visual easter egg a reference and billy
model we're gonna go back to tattooing maybe we'll
probably get your boba fett reference yeah we'll
probably get a boba fett cameo in this he's gonna
nod to the camera and then be gone all right guys
well what did you think about this trailer leave
your thoughts down below i absolutely loved it
um hey subscribe click that bell there's
more to cover we'll talk about it soon